اكد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر ان اداره الرئيس بايدن تدرس
الخيارات المتوفره امامها لاقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله وفي معرض رده على ما نشره
موقع اكسيوس ان الوزير بلينكن وجه طاقمه
بالبحث عن امكانيه الاعتراف رسميا بدوله
فلسطينيه مستقله اضاف ميلر ان الاداره
الامريكيه تؤمن ان اقامه تلك الدوله هي
افضل وسيله لحل الصراع بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيل
نؤيد انشاء دوله فلسطينيه المستقله ونقوم
بالكثير من العمل داخل الحكومه لايجاد
الطرق المثلى لتحقيق ذلك وكجزء من هذا
العمل ننظر في الخيارات التي تشكل جزءا من
عمليه التخطيط المعتاده ونضعها على طاوله
البحث ونستكشف امكانيه نجاح وفعاليه كل
منها ثم نختار افضلها لن اخذ في تفاصيل
هذه العمليه لكن نعم نحن نسعى بنشاط
لانشاء دوله فلسطينيه مستقله مع ضمانات
امنيه حقيقيه لاسرائيل ذلك لاعتقادنا ان
هذه افضل وسيله لتحقيق السلام والامن
الدائمين لاسرائيل
والفلسطينيين
والمنطقه للمزيد من التحليل معنا الان من
نيويورك الدكتور لورنس فريمان كبير الباحث
في مركز الدراسات الدوليه ارحب بك دكتور
معنا اذا هل واشنطن فعلا بصدد مراجعه
سياساتها بشان هذه القضيه بشكل عام القضيه
الفلسطينيه ما اصبح واضحا لبعض الناس في
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن هو ان
بنيامين نتنياهو لن يوافق على ذلك حيث ان
نتنياهو كرر في الفتره الاخيره كما دائما
انه لن يسمح بقيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
واداره بايدن علقت بحقيقه انها قدمت الدعم
منقطع النظير لاسرائيل بعد احداث السابع
من اكتوبر ونتنياهو يستفيد من هذا الدعم
وبايدن لم يتمكن كان من تحرير نفسه من
نتنياهو ومن هذه العلاقه بالعوده الى ط
تاريخ بنيامين نتنياهو ليس لديه اي رغبه
باحلال دوله فلسطينيه هو اما يريد ان يقتل
الفلسطينيين او يهجر الفلسطينيين ولكنه ضد
الدوله الفلسطينيه يتعين على الاداره
الامريكيه ان تفكر بالخيارات ولكن
الخيارات محدوده طالما ان نتنياهو موجود
بالتالي هل هذه خطوه يمكن فهم
مجرد محاوله للضغط على حكومه نتنياهو ام
اننا سنرى نتائج غير ربما مسبوقه من خلال
هذه المراجعه وهذه الخيارات
المطروحه اعتقد ان اداره الرئيس
بايدن
فهمت ما يحصل
هناك طبعا راي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بان الولايات المتحده
تتلقى صفعه على المستوى الدولي بسبب
الموقف الداعم لنتنياهو الذي قتل الالاف
من المدنيين الفلسطينيين نتحدث عن 10 الا
طفل ووالده اذا العالم برمته يشاهد
الفضاءات التي ترتكب في قطاع غزه ونحيي
موقف جنوب افريقيا بالقضيه المرفوعه
بمحكمه العدل ووليه ولكن الشباب الجيل
الجديد في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
يوافق على هذه السياسات الامريكيه هم
يبحثون عن سبيل للري للخروج ولكن لا اعتقد
ان نتنياهو سوف يسبح طالما انه رئيسا
لمجلس الوزراء الفلسطيني بق الاسرائيلي
عفوا بقيام دوله فلسطينيه وبالتالي يجب ان
يكون نتنياهو رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي كي يتم احراز اي تقدم واعتقد
ان الاداره الامريكيه تشعر
بالاحباط طبعا الخطا كان باعطاء الضوء
الاخضر الكامل والدعم العسكري للتحركات
الاسرائيليه طيب تحدثت قبل قليل عن خيارات
محدوده لحل الدولتين قد يتم طرحها هل يمكن
ان نعرف ما هي ما
اهمها
كما سبق و قلت طبعا
الفلسطينيون لديهم حق
بانشاء دوله فلسطينيه اسرائيل لطالما
عارضت هذا المفهوم اسرائيل لا تود
الفلسطينيين ان يكونوا هناك ولكن يجب دعم
الفلسطينيين والعمل يجب ان تبدا على مستوى
الامم المتحده للسماح بالاصوات الفلسطينيه
لكي تصل يجب ان نتعامل مع الفلسطينيين
كدوله ويجب ان نتعامل ونتعاون مع الدول في
المنطقه في المنطقه العربيه وفي الخليج
وفي اوروبا ويجب ان يفهم نتنياهو انه
يعرقل ليس فقط الازدهار الفلسطيني بل
الدوله الاسرائيليه هو فشل في تامين الامن
الاسرائيلي ومن خلال قتل عشرات الالاف من
المدنيين الفلسطينيين الابرياء هو بحد
ذاته خطر لدوله اسرائيل وبالتالي هذا ما
يجب ان يعمل عليه قاده العالم اللا يكون
نتنياهو على راس الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولكن
الامر يبدا باعطاء صوت للفلسطينيين على
مستوى الامم المتحده وفي كل انحاء العالم